hallo mein Name ist willkommen meine
lieben Freunde ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einer
neuen Episode goat Simulator 3
zuallererst würde ich sagen bewegen wir
uns rüber zu unserem ziegenturm hier
vorne wo ist unser
[Musik]
weg
eine ganz kurze schweige Sekunde okay
reicht das nächste Klo wird irgendwie
dies bauen ich glaube die machen nach
jedem Mal wo ich das Spiel beende
einfach die Map noch mal komplett neu
damit nicht alles irgendwie
bin ich gerade durch das Ding
durchgespamt
[Applaus]
wir haben auf jeden Fall eine Menge zu
tun in der heutigen Episode meine lieben
Freunde denn ich habe den Plan den
großen Plan unsere zu entdecken
wenn ihr denkt das hier war es schon nö
nö nö nö nö nö nö nö
ich will bis hier oben reisen heute
deswegen setzen wir einen Wegpunkt
und das ist das Ziel für heute den
Sekunden später
[Musik]
ich kann Traktor fahren
ich habe nie drauf meine Augen oben
sehen wir dass der Wegpunkt jetzt
ziemlich mittig liegt von daher fahren
wir in die Richtung auch einfach mal los
mit unserem kleinen Traktor hey das ist
so Wahnsinn man kann alles hier voll
fahren ich kann Leute überfahren
Vogelscheuchen hier es ist so viel
geiler als goat Simulator 1 ich habe
brutal Bock auf diese Spiel und einfach
du willst mir sagen ich kann Baum oben
fahren ich kann alles machen aber hier
da komme ich nicht durch oder was der
Typ da vorne regt mich auch schon die
ganze Zeit auf
[Applaus]
ich bin schon wieder durch hindurch
oh das hier vorne soll glaube ich ein Q7
darstellen oder irgendwie so egal wir
nehmen den Traktor meine lieben Freunde
[Musik]
ist wahrscheinlich für Multiplayer das
dann wenn ich das irgendwie mal mit
Sandra oder irgend jemand anders zocke
dass diese Personen fahren kann da ich
allerdings keine Freunde habe müssen wir
alleine weiterfahren ich würde sagen wir
machen mal wieder ein bisschen Turbo
hier und oh nein nein nein nein nein
nein
kann ich im Wasser mit ich kann mit
Turbo und Wasser weiterfahren okay das
ist geil ein paar Sekunden später
okay machen wir zu Fuß weiter meine
lieben Freunde da vorne müssen wir hin
kann dir jetzt irgendwie Thomann ja die
kann auch Turbo schwimmen aber gibt's
auch Schiffe gibt's Boote ey es gibt
noch warum macht sie schon wieder das
mit ihm wirklich es gibt so unfassbar
viele Dinge für uns zu entdecken in
diesem Spiel ich sag's euch ich werde
dieses Projekt auch safe noch nicht
normal weiterlaufen ich werde dieses
Projekt safe dort oben
[Musik]
ich
oh mein Gott
ich habe den
die das in jedem Baum
jetzt nicht
aber die hier wird dir so komisch
geklettert oder dieser Typ oder Weg
junge da oben ist noch irgendwas da
müssen wir hin können wir hier vorne
hochklettern können wir auch machen
kann mich nicht daran machen wir noch
mal
einmal oben drauf jetzt vielleicht zack
ich habe vorhin da unten auch schon
Statue eingesammelt habt ihr vielleicht
gesehen ich bin in den ganzen Berg
hochgekraxelt ich habe auch eine
Bowlingbahn entdeckt allerdings ist
unser Ziel ja wirklich der Luftballon da
oben keine Ahnung warum ich jetzt so
hoch gesprungen man gerade aber wir
haben so unfassbar viel zu entdecken in
diesem Video an nicht wie doll ich mich
auf die nächsten Teile voll schaut euch
das mal an
und das ist nur dieses Mido fields oder
irgendwie so es gibt noch so viel mehr
zu entdecken Leute ey ich habe so Bock
auf dieses Spiel oh mein Gott Leute ich
bin vorne beim Ballon angekommen ich
weiß nicht ob ich über diese Seite
irgendwie rüber gehen kann grindan mit
er okay krass ich bin drin
ich bin im Ballon
kann ich jetzt
oh
warum bin ich
das ist denn jetzt los immer
nicht losfliegen oder muss ich das Teil
dafür eigentlich kaputt machen
das geht nicht ich kann hier
ich habe vergessen auf grindanten zu
drücken
ich bin aber ganz ehrlich leute ich darf
mich hier nicht die ganze Zeit von
irgendwelchen geilen Sachen ablenken
lassen ich meine schaut euch das mal an
die Grafik die Welt allein wo wir hier
gerade schon sind ist ihre da vorne ist
ein Wasserpark da hinten hinter diesem
blau lilanen Gebäude hier ist auf jeden
Fall auch noch eine Bowlingbahn das hier
soll glaube ich ein Ikea sein also der
Tisch heißt auf jeden Fall Kaka
ist das stark ich liebe die Entwickler
von diesen schwierig ich kriege keinen
einzigen Cent hier für ne aber es ist so
geil es ist so viel Liebe zum Metall
schon immer an hier eine Pizza
Lieferanten Dings da vorne ist die
Bowlingbahn die ich vorher erwähnt habe
wir müssen uns allerdings ein Auto
schnappen vorhin standen ihr noch welche
die habe ich aber gleich alle in die
Luft gesprengt allerdings ist hier vorne
schon Polizeiauto das habe ich einfach
mal
[Musik]
haben wir auch noch
oh mein Gott
auf jeden Fall eine Straßensperre jetzt
bin ich irgendwie durch Teer gelaufen
und hat Entschuldigung ey das sieht die
ganze Zeit und so also hier können wir
auf jeden Fall den zu reingehen Ticket
brauchen wir glaube ich nicht kaufen
weil wir sind eine Ziege diesen primär
wegen uns da ach chillig
dem Wahl geht's gut wir haben hier vorne
noch ein gift shop also in Souvenirladen
so können wir ja auch Verwüstung
anrichten hey wir können alles machen in
diesem Spiel was haben wir hier so ein
Ding was ist das jetzt haben wir eine
strengen limitierte Baseball cap-linie
okay nice will sieht auf jeden Fall
stabil aus wir haben hier vorne Gazellen
sehe ich hier schon kann ich da auch
einfach mal rein das sind ja quasi meine
Verwandten ne moin
geht's dir gut
irgendwie nichts mit mir egal wir haben
ganze
[Musik]
hallo
ich heiße kleine Ziege kann eine Giraffe
okay ich darf mich nicht so viel
ablenken lassen Freunde das muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen ich muss weiter ich
will die ganzen Map heute entdecken und
ich sehe jetzt schon wieder nach
Rohraufnahme dass wir extrem weit sind
von daher keine ich will am liebsten
timeless wach runter hinfahren aber es
ist so geil ich will alles entdecken ich
liebe dieses Spiel ich liebe goat
Simulator guck mal wir fahren jetzt mal
hier rechts rein wir haben hier vorne
schon die Großstadt es geht schon los
hier vorne mit den riesigen Hochhäusern
da hinten müsste dann sogar auch
irgendwo der Strand sein haben ja wir
haben überall Turbo jedes Auto Turbo
Entschuldigung Entschuldigung Achtung
Scheiße Ampel Entschuldigung wir können
mir weiter davon wir haben die Golden
Gate Bridge oh nein schon wieder ins
Wasser jetzt
genau so fahre ich auch immer das hier
soll wahrscheinlich der Hafen von San
Francisco sein so ein bisschen von daher
gehst du erstmal ganz kurz schwimmen
tschau wir haben da eine Golden Gate
Bridge und hier die Grafik ist blöd
oh ey dass ich zum Trocknen meine
tastatur spinnt ne
perfekt
dieser Angst vor mir
völlig unbegründet
das sieht
war das denn ist das ein Schuh
ich habe einen Schuh Entschuldigung
jungs ihr habt hier euren Schuh verloren
irgendwie
also wir sind mittlerweile hier vorne
angelangt das hier ist der
Anfangsbereich wo wir waren es ist echt
irre Nächte hier vorne weil dieser Berg
wo wir drauf waren dass sie mir hier an
der Brücke und sowas allem wir müssen
halt um hier alles so ein bisschen
freizuschalten von der Map diese
ziegentürme erobern ne das war ja auch
der ziegenturm an dem wir hier waren wo
wir das Dixi Klone der letzte Folge
hingestellt haben die müssen wir
synchronisieren so dass wir dort quasi
mal wieder hinzubauen können deswegen
setze ich jetzt hier erstmal einen
Wegpunkt hin so dass wir zu dem anderen
Ziegen Turm da vorne hingehen guck mal
da vorne steht da sieht es schon da
komplett der große Strahl raus hier
vorne haben wir noch so eine komische
Kiste da steht allerdings nur mehr
Spieler Modus erhältlich ey das ist echt
irre wir müssen auf jeden Fall demnächst
den Mehrspielermodus austesten in der
letzten Folge solltet ihr mir in die
Kommentare schreiben mit wem ich das
ganze Spiel mal spielen soll da haben
ganz viele Sandra geschrieben ich habe
mir natürlich direkt Bescheid gegeben
und sie meinte auch sie wäre auf jeden
Fall dabei die ist gerade noch in Wien
das heißt es wird erst demnächst dann
der Fall sein allerdings werde ich auf
jeden Fall mit Sandra eine Runde
aufnehmen und ich habe auch schon
paluten geschrieben weil er auch ein
riesen Gold Simulator Fan ist von daher
wird auch mit paluten Folge kommen komme
ich hier
wie komme ich dann ach so
ist ein Weg
ja es wird auf jeden Fall auch mehr
Spieler Videos geben hier auf meinem
Kanal ich liebe dieses Spiel oh nein
ich bin so guck mal warum digga kann ich
nicht theoretisch wenn ich immer weiter
hier auf dem Boot springe sogar bis da
oben hinkommen ja schaut mal sagt noch
einen höher nee dann nebenher so per
perfekt ey ich liebe dieses Spiel als
wenn die sich für alles irgendeine
Lösung überlegt hätten ne halten wir er
gedrückt synchronisieren wir uns mit dem
Turm hier und haben jetzt tatsächlich
diesen Bereich auch entdeckt und jetzt
müsste das glaube ich auch in unserer
Karte vermerkt sein er wird Präsident
gewählt hier Alter
ein bisschen darstellen mit der ganzen
Werbung hier vorne allerdings ist das
glaube ich so eine Mischung aus San
Francisco und New York und wenn wir
jetzt m drücken sehen wir schon wir
haben diesen Bereich
San Angora heißt das wir haben auch hier
einige Quest die wir alle noch machen
müssen meine lieben Freunde wir haben
auch hier noch ganz viele Quest die wir
auch noch machen müssen und das haben
wir noch alles gar nicht entdeckt ich
bin allerdings in der ruderteil schon
fast bei der halben Stunde und dieses
Video hier soll auch kein Podcast werden
von daher meine lieben Freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat lasst einen Daumen
hoch unter diesem Video da abonniert
meinen Kanal und Klick auf die Glocke
weitere Teile goat Simulator 3D zu
verpassen ich freue mich ja alles mit
euch zu entdecken in der nächsten Folge
immer mal auf das Hochhaus da hinten
drauf und fahren mal nach der ganz
hinten
zum letzten Ende
in der nächsten Folge synchronisieren
wir alles wir entdecken die ganze Map
dann haben wir die ganzen Map
freigeschaltet in der übernächsten Folge
machen wir dann die Challenges wir haben
so viel zu tun es wird zu stressig aber
ich habe so Bock geil wir sehen uns